Namo tassa bhagavato harahato sama sambuddhasa Namo tassa bhagavato harahato sama sambuddhasa
Namo tassa bhagavato arahato sama sambuddhasa Karaniyangatta kusalena yantang santang padang rabhi same ca sako uju ca suju ca suvaco ca samudu anati mani
santu sako čá subháro čá apá ti čo čá sává huká utí santen ryo čá nipá ko čá apá gábo kulej suá nálu dvído ná čá ku dán samá čá rekenčí jená viňupá reupá vadejum
Suki no vakemi no hontu, save sata vavantu suki tata.
Je kechi pana butati, tasa vata varava anavasesa.
Tiga vaje ma hantava, majima rasa kanu katula.
Dítává jevá adítá, ječá důlej vás santi avidůlej.
Vůtává samba vezívá, sábej sátá bavantu sukítatá.
Napároparání kubéta, natimáňatá katáčinén keňčí.
Vyjaru sána pátiga sáňa, naňa manja sádukáňi čejá.
Matája táňi jáň půdháň, naňu sájka půdháň aňu rákej.
Evámpí sába půdhej sůl, mána sámbává je apáry máň.
Mějteň čá sába lokáň míň,
Manasambhavaje apari-manam.
Udanga-docha-tiri-ancha.
Asampatanga-veranga-sapatam.
Titancharan-nisinova.
Sayano-vaya-vatasa-vigatam-do.
Eitan-satinga-diteya.
Brahma-gedang-vihara-idamahu.
Dítinča anupagam vásilava, dasanena sampano, kamesu vinejagedam, nahidjatukabaseam, punare titi.
May all beings be free of physical pain.
May all beings be free of mental distress.
May all beings be liberated of all their suffering.
May all beings live in contentment and joy.
Ať všechny bytosti žijí v spokojenosti a radosti.
Ať všechny bytosti žijí v míru a harmonii.
Ať všechny bytosti dokončí míru a požehnání a podvlaženosti vám.
Sábe sáta sukita hantu.
Sādhu, Sādhu, Sādhu.
Když se můžeme představit do konce kursu, mysl se určitě představí.
Začíná mysl na to, co budu dělat zítra, pozítří, popozítří, příští týden, příští rok a tak.
Takže pro nás je to zajímavé, protože nám to ukazuje naše vzájemství s světem.
protože nám to ukazuje náš vztah ke světu, co od něho očekáváme, naše naděje, a tak.
Ale samozřejmě neměli jsme to umít opadnout.
Většinou plány, které si uděláme na kurzu,
jsou naprosto protichůdné skutečnosti.
Protože zatímco jsme tady byli šest dnů, chodili pomalu a označovali.
Svět tam linků se pohnel.
i když to já nejsem si úplně jistý, ještě existuje.
Takže nezapomeňte, že od teď, dokud nesmíme, je také velmi důležitá část naší práce.
Jděte na slyšení s myšlením na hlavu nebo nějakým krásným myšlením,
A samozřejmě to okřesné rozhodnutí probudit se s zvonkem.
Slyšte dobře.